now the other nice thing about this
number is that if ever a thief have
finds a briefcase with a lock on it
belonging to a physicist the first
number he should try to unpick that
briefcase is just type in 1 3 7 because
it's the sort of number that comes into
the head of so many physicists beautiful
number I think class your personal
question yeah
is it the combination to your briefcase
I don't have a lock of my briefcase
nobody would find anything useful in it
anyway it's such a mess well I thought
it would be nice to talk about the
so-called fine structure constant this
is widely used in atomic physics when
we're trying to understand the motion of
electrons around atoms and the nature of
the very small splittings between the
sharp lines in the spectra of atoms but
what I like about Alpha is that it
combines three fundamental constants you
know in a rather beautiful way so is
this is called the fine-structure
constant and so it's given by e squared
YZ the charge of the electron over h-bar
times C so here's h-bar that's Planck's
constant divided by 2 pi and here C is
the speed of light and that number is we
describe that number as dimensionless
it's not in centimeters or seconds it's
just a plain beautiful number and its
value is 1 over 137 - a very good
approximation and I think the fact that
this this number is independent of units
it makes it it makes it a very
fundamental number in science and one in
which as well that if you're decide to
want to get in touch with some
aliens on some distant planet going
around orbiting around a star perhaps a
bit like our own Sun it would be one of
the numbers you would signal to these
aliens if you indicate that we have a
scientific and technological
capabilities planet so for example it
wouldn't be much use if you communicate
it with them and said look I waited 8
kilograms and my height is one it what
one meter eighty these numbers wouldn't
mean anything to them what would mean
something to them is the value of this
fine structure constant alpha because
they would have they would know that
number as well if they have made if
they've made telescopes and have got
electronic equipment and sending out
radio waves and so on they will know
that number for sure there are a couple
of other numbers as well that you could
send them one would be for example the
ratio of the mass of the proton to the
electron and that's something like 1840
so if you send numbers like 1 over 137
or indeed perhaps more conveniently just
137 or
1840 he would then the alien
civilization would say right these
people understand science and technology
understand quantum mechanics so it'd be
a really nice number to send out to them
oh yes this is a to me this is a very
interesting number and I bought my
colleagues in the in particle cosmology
and particle physicists and so on about
this number I've fuse any ideas about it
but I won't go into those of it they
take too long but it's been it's been a
topic of great interest I mean you will
find very learning text on the magic of
alpha it's a magical number I mean
Feynman for example in his classical
those three classic textbooks he wrote
for the undergraduate courses at at
Caltech I can't quote from him directly
but he felt that this was a number you
know that was that all physicists are
very very deeply attached to and almost
has a magic to it because you there's no
theory that explains why it has the
value it has I mean this is the mystery
of it is just this value but you can be
sure that if the value are a little bit
different from the value it actually has
we wouldn't be around here talking about
it now you know atomic physics is relies
is the way it is because of the value of
alpha and you know in universes you
could cosmologists are now talking about
universes in which alpha could be
different in which these three constants
the make up alpha could be different and
you know then physics chemistry
biochemistry would be totally different
and we might not be around to talk about
it so the value of alpha is very very
special
we still don't know why it has the value
it has well I probably don't speak that
much to laypeople your first I've spoken
to for a long time most of my work
involves to teaching the graduates and
working with my colleagues on research
and going to conferences so it's I think
it's a little perhaps a little bit
recherche four four four I mean ideally
actually isn't that complicated I think
it's very fascinating so I'm glad to
talk to you about it today and maybe
it'll get a bit better known
you